هل تشعر أن الحكومة المصرية
أساءت تقدير التوقعات العالمية منذ
آخر قرض من صندوق النقد الدولي والجيش المصري
قد وضع
تقليديًا دورًا كبيرًا في الاقتصاد ، فهل
ستخطو الحكومة خطوات لمراجعة مشاركة
الجيوش
في القطاع الخاص
والاقتصاد إذا كان الأمر كذلك ، فكيف؟  قريباً أعتقد أنه
يمكننا الرجوع إلى المؤسسة المملوكة للدولة
وقد أصدرنا للتو ورقة
تحدد سياسات الحكومة في
إدارة المؤسسة المملوكة للدولة وما
سيتم توفيره في القطاعات التي سيتم
بيعها للقطاع الخاص
لتشجيع المزيد  الاستثمار وأعتقد
أننا مدعومون ومتجاهلون من قبل
برنامج صندوق النقد الدولي حاليًا ، لذا فنحن كآخرين
نعاني بالضرورة ولكننا أعتقد
أننا نضع اللوائح
والحوافز والأطر في
تنفيذ برنامج صندوق النقد الدولي وفي
التعامل مع التحديات أثناء
كما تدرك البعد الاجتماعي أه
وتتعامل معه أيضًا
لأنك لا تستطيع معالجة هذه القضايا على
سبيل المثال  cept بطريقة شمولية